is there something interesting about
earth or other planets in terms of
weather patterns so we talked
a lot about volcanic
patterns is there something else about
weather that's interesting like storms
or variations in temperature all those
kinds of things
yeah so there's sort of every
planet and moon has a kind of
interesting and unique weather pattern
and
those weather patterns are really we
don't have
a good understanding of them we don't
even have a good understanding of the
the global circulation patterns um
of of many of these atmospheres why the
storm systems occur
so the the
composition and occurrence of storms and
clouds in these objects is another one
of these
kind of windows into the interior that i
was talking about with surfaces one of
these
ways that we can get perspective and
what the composition is of the interior
and
how the circulation is working so
circulation will
bring some species up from deeper in the
atmosphere of the planet to some
altitude that's a little bit colder and
that species will condense out and form
a cloud at that altitude
and we can detect in some cases what
those clouds are composed of
um and looking at
where those occur um can tell you how
the circulation cells are whether
the atmospheric circulation is say
coming up at the equator and going down
at the poles
or whether you have multiple cells in
the atmosphere and
i mean jupiter's atmosphere is is just
insane there's so much going on you look
at these pictures and there's all these
vortices and anti-vortices and you have
these different bands that are moving in
in opposite directions that may be
giving you
information about the the deep
proper like deep in the atmosphere
physically deep properties
of um jupiter's
interior and in circulation um
what are the these vortices what's the
basic material of the storms
it's condensed molecules from the
atmosphere so ammonia ice particles
in the case of jupiter it's methane ice
in the case of
let's say uranus and neptune and other
species you can kind of construct
a chemical model for which species can
condense where and so you see a cloud at
a certain
altitude within the atmosphere and you
can make a guess at what that cloud is
made of
and sometimes measure it directly and
you know different species make
different colors as well
oh cool ice storms okay
i mean the climate of uranus has always
been fascinating to me because it orbits
on its side
and it has a 42-year
orbital period and so you know with
earth our seasons are because our
equator is tipped just a little bit to
the plane that we orbit in so sometimes
the sun lights a little bit above the
equator and sometimes it's a little bit
below the equator but on uranus
it's like for for 10 years the sunlight
is directly on the north pole and then
it's directly on the equator and then
it's directly on the south pole
and it's it's actually kind of amazing
that the atmosphere doesn't look crazier
than
it does but understanding how taking
again like one of these extreme examples
if we can understand
why that atmosphere behaves in the way
it does it's kind of a test of our
understanding of how
how atmospheres so like heats up one
side of the planet
for 10 years and then freezes it
the next like and that you're saying
would
should probably lead to some chaos
and it doesn't the fact that it doesn't
tells you something about the atmosphere
so atmospheres have a property that
surfaces don't have which is that they
can redistribute heat a lot more
effectively right
so there are stabilizing like
self-regulating
aspect to them that they're able to deal
with extreme conditions
but predicting how that complex system
unrolls is is very difficult as we know
about predicting the weather on earth
even
oh my goodness yeah that's the little
variation we have on earth you know
people have tried to
put together global circulation models
so you know we've done this for earth
people have tried to do these for other
planets as well
and it is a really hard problem
so titan for example like i said it's
it's one of the best studied atmospheres
in the solar system and people have
tried to make these global circulation
models and actually predict what's going
to
to happen moving into sort of the next
season of titan and those predictions
have ended up being wrong and so then
you know it's i i don't know it's always
exciting when a prediction is wrong
because it means that
there's something more to learn like
your theory wasn't sufficient
and then you get to go back and learn
something by how you have to modify the
theory
to make it fit i'm excited by the
possibility of one day there will be for
various moons and planets there will be
uh
like news programs reporting the weather
with the fake confidence of
like as if you can predict the weather
you